So first thing you probably notice about
tcpdump data is that there's a lot of
details here.
What is all this options sack stuff?
We're not going to look
at that in this course.
I'm going to wave my magic
wand to make it go away.
I know it's kind of silly to say,
but don't panic about the fact that
this output probably looks
like a big pile of weird.
Some parts of it may jump out at you
as already saying something, and
if not right now,
maybe by the end of this video.
So there are some things in here
you might already recognize.
If you're using your own data, you'll
see your machine's IP address here.
Here's mine.
Notice the just as we saw with ping,
sometimes it shows up to the left of
this little angle bracket and
sometimes it shows up to the right.
That's because some of these
packets are going from our machine
to example.net and
some of them are coming back.
Likewise, here's the IP address for
example.net.
If you want to check that,
you can use the host command
to look it up in the DNS.
Now let's look at something that
differs across these packets.
At the end of each record,
there's a length field that's telling us
how much data was sent in that packet.
That's just the payload,
the actual HTTP, data
as opposed to all the TCP overhead, like
addresses, import numbers, and such.
So the interesting thing here is
that out of all of these packets,
only a few of them even
have any payload data.
For most of them, the length value is 0.
This is an important fact about TCP.
Even before the client and
server get to exchange any real data,
they've got some set up to do
to bring up the connection.
And after they're done with the real
data, they have some tear down to do.
So looking at the first of
these that has any real data,
it says length 38, and
the only other one has length 321.
Well, where did those numbers come from?
Well, let's look back at
what data we actually sent.
Here's our HTTP request, and
if you count these newline characters at
the end of each line as only one,
as the backslash doesn't really count,
it's going to come out
to exactly 38 bytes.
Which means that this record in
the tcpdump data exactly represents
the transmission of the HTTP request
from our client, the example.net server.